with the world's population
growing every year we need to find ways
to produce more food so if we could
bring
dinosaurs back from the dead would you
eat them
how can we bring dinosaurs back from
extinction
[Music]
much would they need to eat each day
and which dinosaur would be the most
delicious
we're sparing no expense things are
becoming jurassic
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if we raised dinosaurs for food
dinosaurs haven't walked the earth for
65 million years
but if we managed to bring them back
could we raise them for food and eat
their meat
just like the movie jurassic park we
could
possibly bring back dinosaurs did you
know that dinosaur dna is
most closely related to chicken dna
but unlike in the movies it wouldn't be
easy to bring dinos back we would need
to have some
dino dna that hasn't deteriorated
and unfortunately that isn't easy to
come by
but let's say we did stumble upon some
suitable dinosaur dna what would be
the next steps well scientists have been
trying to resurrect woolly mammoths by
sequencing their dna from a frozen
specimen
then they synthesized its genes and
placed them
into an asian elephant embryo as
99 of their genomes are similar
we could do the same thing to bring back
dinosaurs
but we'd use a chicken egg instead
then we'd leave it under a heater and
see if a dinosaur hatches
if it were a dinosaur we'd treat it
just like other farm animals we
and we'd need to feed that hungry
dinosaur baby
so how much would a dinosaur need to eat
well if you've watched jurassic park you
know that
dinosaurs come in a range of shapes
and sizes so it depends on
what the dinosaur's diet is for instance
herbivores like the brachiosaurus could
weigh
four kilograms at birth and within a few
months they could easily weigh 10 times
more
once it becomes an adult this
plant-eating giant
would weigh in at a whopping 35 to
56 metric tons
that's about the same as 120
head of cattle and it would need to eat
400 kilograms of food per day
that's how much 16 dairy cows eat in a
day
but let's not forget how much meat that
dinosaur would give you
you'd have quite a feast and
speaking of meat which dinosaur do you
think
would taste best well it's hard to know
because no one alive today has ever
tried dinosaur meat
but if we compare it to the meats we
enjoy
the most delicious tend to be from
herbivores
the plant-eating animals like our
brachiosaurus
something like the infamous t-rex might
taste
a little different we know that
dinosaurs are distant relatives of birds
and
fast-moving dinosaurs would mainly
consist
of white meat so a t-rex
might taste like an ostrich maybe you'd
prefer to eat seafood
well in that case you might want to try
eating dinosaurs that had marine diets
they might have a fishier flavor and
here's one thing you probably hadn't
even thought of
recent studies have shown that dinosaurs
like t-rex had feathers
so if we did raise them for food
imagine plucking a dinosaur that big one
tyrannosaur fossil
had feathers that measured an incredible
one meter long
so it would be a little different than
plucking a chicken
but before we get too carried away we'd
better say that
bringing back dinosaurs is not very
likely
and if we were to do it there would be
other consequences
and maybe some that we couldn't handle
just like in jurassic park things could
get out of hand pretty quickly but if
you think about it
we're already eating dinosaurs or at
least
their very distant relative the chicken
they might be smaller but they sure
taste good
now have you ever thought about what it
would be like
if you lost your sense of taste
that's a horrible thought and that's
also
a story for another what if